I am ruffled from brand new startup
bubble ups its Silicon Valley startup
focused on speech related technologies
so this catchy title deep revelation in
speech processing and analysis is in my
opinion too catchy I will today talk
with you about speech enhancement and
try to convince you that this is a
general problem and it can be a product
and and we can grow a company at the top
of this this product so actually in
terms of speech enhancement there are
human and human interface interface
challenges human and human interface
challenges so as you can see there are a
lot of problems where there is a lot of
noise distortions somebody somebody is
talking in the background there are a
lot of artifacts and actually our our
conversations are not clean and we don't
understand other guy so this is human
human interface and all the
human-machine interfaces so actually
cleaning speech is really important for
human and for machines I think this is a
very good example so kitchen sink is one
of the fundamental noises that is used
for for evaluating speech enhancement so
we want to remove such noises we also
can we also want to remove noises to
enable our vacuum cleaners to understand
what what we want to do actually so we
want to clean speech for for machines
and AI mid speech so how how we can how
we can do this so the this the slide is
pretty simple so we have massive corpus
of data I think it's
the most important thing on this slide
is that never train on the same data
twice for speech and hansman so every
single batch is completely different
it's elastic so the probability that we
have the same audio samples is very well
and of course there are a lot of let's
say fronting technologies we can enhance
speech which we can recognize we can we
can have our user interface dialogues
and this is the the general problem so
how to use know how to enhance this
noisy data into clean so there are a few
few different ways to do this and I will
show you now I will show you how how it
looks and how it feels to enhance speech
so this is bubble ops clear cloud
solution we did it and productor eyes
everybody this is Raul Casas I'm here in
Montevideo Uruguay in the middle of
traffic right next to the palacio
legislativo which is the Parliament
House in Uruguay and we're testing our
speech enhancement algorithms in the
wild in the middle of traffic you can
see that there's motorcycles cars
trucks pluses and right about now we're
gonna get a lot of noise and the traffic
is booing so hopefully our speech in has
been algorithm we'll be able to get rid
of all this noise okay so this was noisy
this was not free and this is clean Oh
Oh working okay
is it muted interesting do you hear
anything
oh here it is okay okay interesting
maybe we will back to it okay sorry for
that so so outline on this fact so I
will talk about a bit about noisy speech
how we can classified the background the
data the traditional speech enhancement
algorithms because for a long time they
were the state of the art in this in
this area and we have also deep neural
network approaches so there are four
different F few different f techniques
and the impact and complexity is
different so we we have to keep in mind
that if you want to do a product we care
about the real-time processing and and
of course closing thoughts so just just
to show you so we have impairment model
so we have we have speech flow human we
have microphone speech can be reverb
rated so that it is there is an echo
inside the room if even now there is an
echo we have non stationary noises we
have stationary noises they have
different in
on this speech some of them are easy to
remove some of them are not
non-stationary noise are very difficult
for classical approach non deep learning
let's say classical and we have of
course competiting talkers so it's it's
called bubble noise so that's why the
company is bubble ups from from bubble
noise and general solutions are are here
so we can use multi microphone arrays
it's pretty simple we can use
beamforming and do reverberation using
multi microphone system but in this case
we don't focus on a multi microphone we
just focus on single microphone single
users bit enhancement so so yeah let's
go to the background of speech how it is
constructed in general so it will be a
brief introduction maybe now how they
will be working now
unfortunately not okay
anyway we have we have this sentence the
best way to learn is to solve extra
problems so we pick this this problems
world and want to find the time domain
signal how it looks like and the signal
is constructed with we phones and we
have different kind Volvo semi Volvo's
Africa its top not so and fricatives
for example a L R P B M Z so why is it
important because every every single
every single phone has different average
power and average SNR so it means that
our speech and kinsmen works well on
some particular phones and some are not
so some are very difficult to
reconstruct so that's why it is quite
important to
keep in mind that we we care about how
the speech is constructed actually and
this is additional background for you I
will not dive deeply into this just to
for your information our speech spectrum
is can be divided into some fundamental
frequencies so we have fundamental
frequency F 0 here we have harmonics of
of course we have 4-month F 1 associated
to the mouth F 2 F 3 and this is
associated with with tongue position so
we can hear you can see this here and we
have of course the third one with oral
cavity I have audio sample synthesized
only using this four months so
synthesizing out speech only using these
four months here and F zero you are able
to synthesize speech that is that
intelligibility is very high meaning
that we understand this sentence so
that's why this this basic components
are quite important and we care about
them and and what about noise and speech
levels may be maybe you know a bit about
SNR what the signal-to-noise ratio so so
we should keep in mind that we don't
care about signal-to-noise ratio about
50 DB because it's pretty clean so I
thought we don't want to enhance this
and we don't want to enhance below -10
DB because it is too noisy so we don't
understand even anything in noisy one so
in classroom hospital SNR is from 5 to
20 in trenches from minus 50 so it's
it's pretty noisy when you talk to
somebody in the trains very difficult to
understand and in restaurants from minus
20 and to the 11 and this came to Aiken
cruising that the general range is from
minus five to 15 and this this range we
treat as our our goal so we want to
enhance speech on in this range because
it is most important for the customers
okay so let's go next and how the signal
looks like so for example here are the
sirens you can see this modulated tones
here and they are pretty regular also
audio
[Music]
maybe one more time no fortunately not
we have sirens we have wind noise and
it's stationary broad spectrum so it's
full field on the whole spectrum of
frequencies here we have on the
modulated tones somewhere here so when
noise is spread along the spectrum we
have also crowd crowd saw the humans so
this is non stationary noise in speech
range so we cannot predict what is the
range of this noise meaning that it's
really complex so these three kinds of
noises I are quite the the background
for this okay and okay so we have this
noises and we want to know we have our
words we want to to know if they are
good and or not and I will tell you
something that that snr signal-to-noise
ratio is not a good quality metrics for
speech enhancement and the general
speech why is it because it is not
related to human perception so
signal-to-noise ratio can be very low so
signal is really noisy and we understand
the sentences so that's why we care
about the quality how speaker produce
and nutrients so general quality of
audio means that it is is it good or bad
so our feeling about this is it noisy or
not and intelligibility so how do we
understand this what has been said so
intelligibility is related mostly to the
is our or our TTS but also in speech
enhancement we we calculate water rate
on in some conditions and how is the
signal understand so at the top we have
some metrics that are objective
and we have some metrics that are
subjective so we have also always at the
end of the product we have human that
evaluates the son on his own perception
and long table but it means nothing but
I think the most important thing is this
this role correlation with overall
sigmund quality so here you have
different metrics it is it is taken from
one of the paper for speech enhancement
from inter speech and and this is a
correlation with overall quality of so
objective test by human and here you can
see that pass is highly correlated with
this so this metric is quite important
in speech enhancement speech quality on
intelligibility we have also many of
them I think that the most important is
NC m and C SII
the resort zone there is also different
metrics but they are quite complex to to
evaluate from my perspective NC m is the
fastest so we can run algorithm on the
data and just get the metric others are
quite complex and it takes time to
evaluate them and the most important
thing that NC m doesn't care about
acoustic model or language model so you
can put this on every every sentence
other matrix care about language and an
understanding so it's not easy to
evaluate on any data we have so we we
care about language in general and and
we have this we have this data and how
we actually measure quality and
intelligibility and we might want to
know and what are the traditional
methods of speech enhancement so in
general it's pretty simple
we have discrete Fourier transform so we
switch from time domain to frequency
domain and we have speech estimation
noise estimation
and multiplication of off spectrum and
then we switch back to the time domain
so we we have inverse discrete Fourier
transform so a basic estimate speech and
noise it's we can we can calculate prior
posterior of SNR of off speech and noise
and just use it as our speech
enhancement algorithm and this is
traditional method but there are called
spectral subtraction and there are a few
problems with it so if we if our gain
for particular element is too big we can
kill speech so basically there is a big
trade-off between how much noisy data we
have as an output and or how much speech
do we want to include in our in our
speech enhanced version and there are
also distortions maybe maybe I will have
I don't know why it doesn't work the
speech anyway it's the good thing is
that it's computational simple and you
can just pick our word man and run this
and it works without any training and
and this is it
spectral subtraction but there are a few
disadvantages over it
yeah and now they are included in the
presentation I think I don't have time
for this maybe at the end we'll have a
chance to presenter view from current
time it work at the beginning and after
okay so maybe I will explain how it
works in spectral domain so we have we
have clean signal you can see black
holes here and so there is no noise
we have noisy with I think it's
stationary noise here and we have
enhanced one and you can see that the
visually that the shorter Fourier
transform looks different meaning that
we have some distortions here and we cut
some kind of signals and you can see
that there are some artifacts here that
are visually it looks very bad even
without any listening and it feels that
it is very artificial so it's not not
natural and the enhanced one in time
domain it looks like this so this is
George now clean we have noisy and
enhanced and we for example here we cut
this speech just like this and and we
treat it as it is a noise okay so this
is about the classical approach and then
we will switch to deep neural network
approaches so there are actually four
different methods which can be applied
so the first one the first one is
conventional statistical so we estimate
speech we have noise model prior and
posterior snr computation
we have suppression rule basically at
the end we have coefficients how we
multiply our shorter group form a
Fourier transform and we have three
different deep neural networks
approaches so the last one is the first
one but but instead of using a classical
approach for voice activity detection we
just switch to neural network to do this
so we just switch our components from
from algorithmic approach very classical
to neural networks to do this and this -
yeah these two are related to each other
and we have two methods for end-to-end
you know networks so the first one is
direct it is e as an example of direct
method we can have auto encoder for
visual image enhancement so we can we
can use it as a as a direct method to
estimate clean speech visually using
CNN's or something else an indirect
method we have also this signal added at
the end so maybe you know maybe there is
a the signal we have is actually clean
so we don't want to enhance it a bit and
suppress our our speech so we we also
might want to add the signal at the end
and use it we've combined outputs of the
network and estimate our clean speech
yeah so we have this for four different
methods and you know you can you can
find speech enhancement algorithm on
inter speech and there are a lot of
different techniques so I will don't
deep dive into it this is and this is a
comparison of spectrum one so from this
from this slide this is the result from
from classical approach with comparison
with with our network
so here we have clean so it's the same
we have enhanced and we have enhanced
DNN I think that the metrics are the
most important here and probably
listening test which is not working so
you can see that as in snr noisy has six
subtractive has eleven our solution had
14 but actually as snr doesn't matter
snr is is a waste of time so we don't
analyze as now we care about task and
intelligibility metrics here so in peski
improvement it's almost twice so just
just don't fall for your knowledge soap
ask above above three three point zero
is almost clean speech and we have also
intelligibility metrics as toy and this
is signal intelligibility in bits so
bits per second so how what would is the
intelligibility in bits so 65 versus
ninety three I think it's it's pretty
okay so this was the old solution from
us and how do we achieve it
unfortunately him not allowed to share
our architecture and the test abroad
approach with you even if I wanted to
but I can I can give you some
impressions what we actually use to
achieve that so the first thing we this
is the the most important thing for the
production ready solution so for
production prototype think we use
blocking format so we had sliding window
in time domain so we we analyze it it in
by frame by frame using losing quite
window in the in the development we have
streaming format so what does it mean to
have streaming format when you send
audio to the cloud
after just few frames
we have enhanced version of these frames
so when we have a view that has one hour
of speech we recalculate the enhanced
version in time while while it has been
being sent so this is streaming
procedure and of course we use Python I
think that the the the killer killer
feature of our development is MATLAB and
GPU cutter I think it's pretty awesome
for the deep learning I know I know that
nobody knows who this GPU cutter maybe
somebody knows nobody anyway you can
create script in MATLAB and compile to
GPU without any any change to the code
of course it can be in specific format
it should be but you can compile it
using GPU coder it's pretty expensive
tool by I recommend it so combining this
tool Python with with 10 so 4 and MATLAB
with GPU coder and of course that's not
100 we were able to prepare very good
solution that that is very cheap for for
for computation and currently we are we
are trying to pour this into embedded I
think it's it's almost finished
so maybe maybe soon we will have a
chance to to take a taste of it and and
we are exploring to to migration to GPU
cutter because some some portions of our
processing are we are using CPU not GPU
because it was quite difficult to port
few algorithms to GPU versions so yeah
so this is it about about tools so this
this product is in in production so you
can download application on on Android
and you can try on bubble apps this
clear cloud web yesterday on after-party
we had a chance to try it so maybe after
after during the break I can show you
how it looks I think that that my
friends liked it but maybe you can ask
them yeah so so this is it from my side
we have four minutes you have raised
some differences so if you if you want
to you can take a photo okay and this is
it speak your mind
thank you for for your patient yeah okay
if you have any questions feel free
maybe maybe I have a chance to know run
this audio yes a question I produce
video and audio professionally and I use
something called
Rx from isotope which also uses as far
as I know neural networks to clean up my
audio right yes I was wondering how does
this compare to that okay so when we
when we provide that our solution I
don't have table for this because it is
it is private but for customers we have
such presentation where we compare each
one of the public metals for speech
enhancement comparing to our one and I
think of course you should contact not
to the engineers but to the sales
management but we have I think we have
compared Apple one some academic
solutions that are publicly available
traditional solutions and what else yeah
there are few web interfaces to do this
also using non-negative matrix
factorization so we have such compare
mint so in terms of intelligibility
I think our is is strained to to do the
best for humans
so so for humans it looks really really
Pleasant for me so we we also focus on
the video creators and content creators
to use it this was one over our target
at the beginning thank you
any other questions okay I have one
minute maybe I can run this I'm here in
Montevideo Uruguay in the middle of
traffic right next to the palacio
legislativo this is the Parliament House
in Uruguay and we're testing our speech
and has been algorithms in the wild and
in the middle of traffic you can see
that there's motorcycles cars trucks
buses and the traffic is moving so
hopefully our speech it has been
algorithm we'll be able to get rid of
all this noise do hear cars or not
barely yeah so yeah this is it it works
Oh own presentation didn't ok so if you
have any questions we can switch to the
break and yeah and you can also apply to
the war zone if you want thank you thank
you very much
you